bonjour monsieur kone sa merci d'être
avec nous conseille de défense demain
jean castex l'annoncé à l'instant a lors
de son discours au sénat
quelle sera la teneur de ce conseil
selon vous écoutez c'est très
probablement la décision de mise en
oeuvre si vous voulez de législation qui
sont qui existe dans le droit français
depuis très longtemps et qui n'ont
jamais été vraiment appliqués dans leur
rigidité soit pour des questions de
jurisprudence soit des questions de
lâcheté des hommes politiques donc on
peut refaire à nouveau un conseil de
défense après de là à la question celle
de savoir qu'est ce qui sera
effectivement mis en oeuvre
je ne crois pas à la nécessité de
nouvelles de réglementation de nouvelles
législations mais super naze que je
comprends rien ne croyez pas à de
nouvelles législations ça veut dire
qu'il y en a en vigueur actuellement qui
serait efficace et qu'on ne sont pas mis
en place
oui absolument écoutez quand on pense
que le après l'attentât que la
décapitation de samuel petit tout à coup
on a découvert qu'ils avaient 237
dossier de gens qui étaient expulsables
où étaient ces dossiers est ce qu'ils
étaient dans la poussière dans le bureau
du ministre l'intérieur
donc pourquoi est ce qu on a fait
semblant pendant longtemps que pour des
raisons de protection des droits de
l'homme on ne pouvait pas appliquée
regarder dans le la chaîne de
responsabilité de la décapitation de
samuel touati l'immeuble et traoui est
un homme qui a un dossier judiciaire
gigantesque
il a attaqué une mosquée d'un immeuble
qui était républicain il a tout cassé
dans la mosquée l'imam républicain n'a
pas voulu porter plainte
cet homme était frappé d'un arrêté
d'expulsion et en plus d'une demande de
déchéance de nationalité qui a été
refusée par le tribunal donc en fait on
est sur quelque chose sur lesquels les
dispositions existent c'était la volonté
politique et judiciaire qui n'existaient
pas et dont vous avez vu hier pour la
première fois saisi en référé le
tribunal administratif de refusé
d'annuler la décision de fermeture de la
mosquée de pantin ça veut dire qu'il ya
effectivement une jurisprudence qui est
en train de s'appliquer que maintenant
différente et je pense qu'on va faire
c'est pas la peine de faire des
moulinets avec les bras il ya qu'à
appliquer la règle pas ses distances
vous avez une réglementation contre
l'antisémitisme si vous expulser tous
les imams qui tient des discours
antisémites en france vous videz
considérablement le stock déjà
monsieur poulin vous êtes d'accord avec
les propos de monsieur kone zain ya une
réglementation déjà existantes et les
gouvernements et d'institutions
judiciaires a peut-être été trop laxiste
oui bien sûr et puis on a des politiques
qui surf sur les moments de crise où ce
sont les émotions qui prime en ayant
pour réponse toujours une réponse légale
de législatives d'inflation législatives
donc des lois d'exception on les ajoute
c'est un mille feuilles qui est là qui
n'est jamais utilisé finalement très peu
alors que les lois existent et que c'est
simplement les moyens qui manquent et la
volonté politique
quand vous avez ce nombre d' obligation
de quitter le territoire français qui ne
sont jamais respectées ou quasiment très
peu
c'est simplement la volonté politique
qui fait qu'elles ne sont pas respectées
et effectivement le nombre de
prédicateurs de haine qui étaient
frappés d'aucune tf
eh bien ils sont nombreux les
radicaliser est-ce aussi dangereux qui
doivent être accompagnés à la frontière
et bien oui ils sont nombreux et ils
sont restés sur le territoire pendant
des années parce que les discours ne
suivent pas les actes ou plutôt les
actes ne suivent pas les discours
donc il ya un vrai problème de la façon
dont les politiques sont des acteurs se
mettent en scène essayent de faire
croire qu'ils font quelque chose quand
elle finalement il se refusait à agir
aujourd'hui je crois que c'est fini de
tergiverser il était important que les
actes suivent les paroles parce que
voilà deux attentats en quinze jours
c'est insupportable pour les populations
françaises qui veulent maintenant des
résultats qui veulent s'assurer que les
gouvernements les protéger ne sont pas
semblant de les protéger
alexis poulain merci d'avoir été avec
nous en direct sur rt francs fin avec
nous pour cette édition spéciale
consacrée à l'attentât de nice je
rappelle ces faits n'attaque au couteau
dans la basilique notre-dame de
l'ascension ce matin vers 9 heures trois
personnes décédées deux dans la
basilique une troisième à proximité de
l'édifice
l'auteur présumé des faits a été
interpellé il est actuellement
hospitalisé le parquet national anti
terroriste a été
une cellule de crise a été ouvert pierre
conesa et nuit toujours avec moi je
rappelle qu'il est aux fonctionnaires
spécialisés des questions stratégiques
internationales toujours en direct sur
arte france monsieur conesa pourquoi la
france est prise pour cible aujourd'hui
je crois que ça dépend qui est
l'accusateur si c'est pour parler des
rohan si vous voulez il règle des
problèmes de politique intérieure et
politique extérieure quand il accuse la
france si vous voulez perdre watts
voudrait être le nouvel attaquant turc
sedat le nouveau leur fondateur de la
turquie moderne c'est turquie moderne et
tente évidemment turquie musulmane bon
est donc une manière pour lui de se
positionner sur ce sujet c'est d'accuser
la france puisque la france était le
modèle de laïcité que atatürk avec aux
pieds quand il a créé la turquie moderne
donc il reste cette question politique
intérieure à travers l'accusation contre
la france ensuite il a un enjeu de
politique internationale c'est à dire
qu'il veut être le leader du monde
sunnite et donc il va essayer de prendre
ce leadership mais il a un problème
structurel si vous voulez ou génétique
c'est qu'il n'est pas arabe et devenir
le nouveau khalife c'est difficile il
peut pas le faire parce qu'il est pas
religieux et il peut pas être le nouveau
sultan puisque effectivement pour les
gaz arables le sultan c'est le principe
de l'occupation ottomane dans l'ensemble
du monde du moyen-orient et du maghreb
donc il est comme les iraniens il
souffre d'un déficit de légitimité qu'il
va compenser avec une politique
agressive dénonciatrice etc
ça c'est le cas de c'est le cas de deux
heures douanes cela dit s'il vous laisse
tout ce discours de la victimisation des
musulmans qui est diffusée un peu
partout dans le monde arabe est
totalement insupportable c'est à dire
que vous avez des gens qui eux mêmes ne
respecte pas le minimum c'est des droits
de l'homme chez eux comme le par exemple
pakistan où l'arabie saoudite qui vont
nous accuser un doux d'être redit
savoure forme et je dirais voulu être
chiite en france qu'en arabie saoudite
et vont bien je suis dit en france qu'en
diront donc quand vous avez des gens
comme ça qui sont même pas capable
d'avoir la distance millimes
intellectuelle minimum et qu'ils
accusent la france
on vit dans un monde extraordinaire
regardez le cas du pakistan il ya une
jeune fille qui a été condamné à mort
pour blasphème mais john chrétienne
par le tribunal de première instance
parce qu'elle avait bu de l'eau dans une
puis réservé aux musulmans
vous imaginez qu'en france en face des
puits réservé aux non musulmans
qu'est-ce qui dirait à ce moment là est
ce qu'il ya eu assez en france il ya eu
un seul imam qui a été égorgé dans une
mosquée et non en france on est à 2 et
donc quand est-ce que si vous voulez ce
genre de discours de la victimisation
qui par nature amnistié tous musulmans
terroristes pas mature si c'est un
musulman qui fait l'acte terroriste et
que cette agence est donc ça ce discours
est totalement intolérables il faut
effectivement le faire cesser
en étant un peu plus agressif sur les
droits de l'homme dans tous ces pays qui
nous donne des leçons
est-ce que vous pensez que la france est
plus ciblé que d'autres pays je parle de
pays européens oui parce que si vous
voulez le moi j'ai toujours reproché à
la france notamment après jacques chirac
d'avoir suivi les états unis dans les
guerres qu'ils ont déclenché un peu
partout dans le monde arabe en libye au
mali etc
c'est à dire que le monde arabe est
divisée aujourd'hui par les guerres de
religion il faut le reconnaître en
afghanistan au pakistan en syrie en irak
à bahreïn au yémen et même aux nigériens
vous avez une guerre sunnite chiite
évidemment vous avez aussi ce
contentieux arabie saoudite iran est ce
que c'est à nous d'intervenir dans une
guerre de religion
là où le président chirac avait dit non
il faut pas intervenir militairement sur
l'irak parce que on est face à un
problème qui va être beaucoup plus
important on vous avez à l'opposé vous
avez un président hollande qui va
envoyer des trouver sarkozy qui va
envoyer des troupes des avions en
français pour bombarder la libye est
fait on faire tomber le régime de
kadhafi mais est ce que c'est à nous de
le faire c'est ça que je comprends pas
donc à la fin on se retrouve avec des
attentes interroger sur notre territoire
avec des gens qui tuent des français en
expliquant que c'est pour venger les
musulmans du moyen-orient c'était le
discours des salaires des terroristes du
bataclan donc il ya aussi un recadrage
de la politique extérieure française
s'il ya des guerres sunnites chiites et
ma foi il ya des choses contre
lesquelles on peut rien il n'y a pas de
raison de déclencher une guerre mondiale
à cause de ça est ce que c'est
réellement possible de lutter contre le
fléau qu'est le terrorisme on sait qu'il
ya des pays qui y sont confrontés depuis
des années malheureusement qu'il n'y
arrive pas à y faire face
oui mais encore une fois le terrain
c'est une forme d'action c'est pas un
objectif politique
l'objectif politique c'est qu'elles sont
les idéologies qui légitime le
terrorisme on a eu des différentes
formes de terrorisme on a eu du
terrorisme régionaliste avec les bases
qu'on a été loin des courses etc etc
bon finalement tous ces problèmes se
sont réglés là on est face à une
idéologie qui veut la destruction pure
et simple
si vous voulez des civilisations
occidentales avec les basques avec les
corses on avait du séparatisme si vous
voulez mais séparatisme de l'époque un
régionaliste pas comme il est passé
aujourd'hui est donc l'idée que si vous
voulez on est face à une idéologie qui
avait une emprise extraordinaire et
contre laquelle il faut aller à la
racine pour prendre un exemple quand
l'imam khomeiny condamne le livre de
salman rushdie
il ya vingt-six états musulmans qui
condamne le bouquin qui l'interdisent
alors qu'il ne l'avait même pas lui bon
en plus vous avez eu une tentative
d'assassinât contre le traducteur
italien contre le producteur japonais du
libre donc on est bien face à un espèce
de pieuvre qui étend ses tentacules
absolument partout on n'aura pas l'aide
des pays musulmans pour combattre ce
fléau
par contre effectivement il faut être
très ferme dans la coopération entre
états européens
si vous voulez je prends toujours un
exemple patti les attentats de 95 en
france métro port royal
il a fallu dix ans dix ans pour avoir
l'extradiction du responsable du réseau
qui était en angleterre qui avait un
statut de réfugié politique
donc si vous voulez les états
occidentaux se reste encore si vous
voulez très en deçà de ce qui est la
gravité de la situation et donc il faut
aller beaucoup plus loin si vous voulez
dans cette coopération et des états qui
veulent pas y collaborer bien il faut
pas échangé d'information avec un merci
monsieur connaisseurs vous restez avec
nous on vous êtes toujours en direct sur
rt france est tout de suite en autres
invités nous sommes rejoints françois
chavance ib général de brigade
monsieur chauvancy merci d'être avec
nous en direct sur rt france première
qui est une réaction suite à cet
attentat à nice matin
disons le clairement je rejoins beaucoup
d'ailleurs tout ce qu'a dit monsieur
pierre connaît ça nous sommes en guerre
mais nous ne sommes pas en guerre contre
des armes organisée en étant guerre
contre des individus qui s'arrogent le
droit de tuer d'autres gens au nom de la
religion
donc je dirais mon discours où mon
message c'est vrai on doit lutter contre
ces gens même si c'est très difficile
d'organiser la lutte contre des
individus et on doit faire preuve d'une
incroyable sinon énorme détermination
pour bien laissé comme message à ces
gens là qui ne gagneront pas voilà c'est
mon message socialiste
tout le monde part du renforcement de la
sécurité un notamment autour des lieux
de culte ou des écoles en tout cas en
général sur tout le territoire comment
on procède à ce renforcement de sécurité
nous sommes le problème il est très
simple on ne peut pas tout garder
donc je dirais que l'effort de sécurité
aujourd'hui ne peuvent pas tout faire et
en plus nous sommes dans une période
qu'ovide avec tout autre contrôle donc
faire face à tout n'est pas possible
personnellement je considère que des
mesures devaient être prises pour
peut-être favoriser la protection au
moins dans un premier niveau par les
citoyens d'une partie de leur sécurité
prenons le cas des églises on sait
parfaitement qu'on ne pourra pas garder
chacune des quarante sept mille églises
françaises ce n'est pas possible donc
sans doute il faudrait que ces églises
assurent au sein de leur communauté
cette protection au moins initial qui
est celle d'une fouille éventuelle d'un
contrôle visuel nous arrange pas des
pouvoirs de police
mais je crois que le citoyen aujourd'hui
à d'être associé à cette sécurité face à
des terroristes qu'on ne maîtrise pas on
ne peut pas prévoir un acte mines
attaques individuelles
donc il faut prendre d'autres mesures et
arrêtez de nous dire il n'ya que la
police qui peut faire si le citoyen ne
ne mènerait pas en situation d'assurer
une partie sa propre sécurité
il est aussi responsable de l'acte
terroriste parce qu'il n'a pas fait ce
qu'il fallait
monsieur france y est ce que vous
estimez qu'actuellement la menace
terroriste s'intensifier en france
non je n'ai pas l'impression nous sommes
actuellement dans un phénomène
excitation d'individus suite notamment
aux caricatures de mahomet est gay qui
ont été heureux d'y diffuser avec des
appels et finalement aussi au meurtre
mais objectivement non qu'est ce que
c'est si je peux me permettre que
quelques cas comme symbolique qui
viennent d'arriver
nous sommes dans des cases symbolique
nous ne sommes pas dans des actes de
terrorisme de masse alors que faire bah
je répète et pour se défendre il faut
qu'on estime et notre sécurité
donc le terrorisme sourire avec mais
surtout que le terroriste islamique ne
crois pas qu'il va gagner et ça pour lui
montrer notre détermination
monsieur conesa est ce que le terrorisme
qui est un ennemi on veut dire non
identifiables est ce que c'est ça qui me
rend si difficile à atteindre
il a toujours l'initiative de du moment
du lieu et de la cible et ça ça rend si
vous voulez toute idée de protection
passive comme protéger les églises pour
dg des écoles etc
rassurante pour la population mais
totalement inefficace
donc effectivement je suis assez
d'accord avec ce que disait général
chauvancy parce qu'effectivement les
citoyens d'un petit collaborer
maintenant l'attentât de nice à montrer
autre chose c'est que c'est la police de
proximité qui a été la première sur le
terrain qui a pu neutraliser l'individu
et donc on a longtemps évité ce débat
corporatiste qui est faut-il armes et
les polices locales
quand on sait le travail qui est
d'habilitation qu'impose le ministère de
la défense pour permettre d' armée une
police municipale
en fait on sait très bien que les gens
sont très bien formés et ce n'est pas du
tout des cowboys
donc arrêtons ce débat très
corporatistes que continue à défendre la
police nationale française en disant
vous comprenez les élus et policiers
locaux c'est pas des officiers de police
judiciaire tous les policiers nationaux
sont pas des officiers de police
judiciaire donc il faut arrêter les crs
judiciaire donc il faut arrêter ce débat
idiot et évidemment c'est une police
locale qui connaît le mieux à la fois la
géopolitique de la ville et en même
temps la géopolitique des risques donc
voilà il ya une réserve si vous voulez
qu'ils pourraient être facilement
règlement dit reggae par des processus
législatif
monsieur conesa monsieur sauvant si vous
êtes en direct avec nous sur rt front
national et nous nos deux invités
toujours en direct en pierre conesa aux
anciens hauts fonctionnaires spécialiste
des questions stratégiques
internationales et puis françois
chaumont si général de brigade nos deux
invités en direct sur notre antenne
monsieur souvent si jean castex le
premier ministre est bien évidemment
ex-premier après 7 octobre
il a appelé à l'unité et à la cohésion
est ce que vous trouvez que les climat
actuel en france est propice à un climat
de cohésion et d'unité
je crois que la situation face au
terrorisme islamique faut-il encore le
rappeler et est claire je crois qu'aucun
français aujourd'hui ne se permettrait
d'avoir une position différencier de
face au terrorisme islamique tout le
monde aux têtes unis c'est une évidence
même s'il peut y avoir des désagréments
des désaccords ont très bien mais je
crois que ce serait une fausse polémique
les appels à l'unité sont nécessaires je
crois que la classe politique est uni
maintenant nous entendons comme à chaque
fois nous ne laissons pas faire
il faut être déterminé nous serons
implacables on va c'est bien de parler
des frais et agit en monsieur conesa est
ce que vous estimez qu'il faut encore
renforcer la sécurité notamment aux
abords des lieux de culte non je vous
dis tout ça c'est une conception de la
sécurité une conception facile de la
sécurité c'est à dire on protège
certains dieux mais rappelez vous la
polémique qui a suivi l'attentât devant
les anciens locaux de charlie hebdo
pourquoi protéger les anciens locaux
charlie-hebdo c'était évidemment pas une
mission de sécurité et donc il se trouve
que le terroriste s'était même pas au
courant qu'elle ait plus personne dans
les lieux et qu'on me laisse y était
pour le voulait passer de déranger
pourriels a donné deux coups de hache à
des femmes qui étaient là à côté
comment voulez vous lutter contre ce
type de thé heureuse maintenant moi je
voudrais revenir sur un concept que je
dénonce il n'y a pas d'union nationale
c'est pas vrai après laffaire samuel
pâtit je me suis amusé à regarder ce que
le collectif contre l'islamophobie en
france avaient écrit et je le suis
depuis un certain temps ils n'ont jamais
condamné un attentat des rues c'est la
première fois cette fois ci qu'il
condamne un attentat mais sans nommer la
cause de cet attentat
c'est à dire que jamais ils n'ont
reconnu la responsabilité de l'islam ou
d'un musulman dans ses attentes un bon
deuxième chose j'ai regardé aussi les
sites de tous et vous savez toutes ces
sectes séparatistes les indigènes de la
république les associations noires de
france etc
aucune n'a condamné la décapitation de
samuel petit pourquoi parce qu on est
dans une société qui s'est
considérablement fragmentée où chacune
de ces sectes si vous voulez considère
que son projet politique est supérieur à
celui de la république donc ils sont pas
prêts à se solidariser en plus qui
ciblent effectivement longue blanc
machiste qui est l'ennemi principal
donc vous voyez dans quel fausse union
nationale on se trouve on n'est pas du
tout dans une situation comment dire de
quoi qui a précédé la guerre de 14
c'était dernière remarque c'est
peut-être rassurant c'est qu'apparemment
les insoumis ont l'air de découvrir que
la menace islamiste est supérieure à
celle du front national donc je veux
dire commutation intellectuelle c'est
intéressant même mélenchon on arrive a
condamné les attentats
hollande ou conesa est ce que vous
estimez que le cci f1 doit condamner les
attentats terroristes plus que d'autres
associations
et pourquoi écouter le ciel seief moi je
les ai contactés en 2014 sont voyez ça
remonte à loin
je voulais rencontrer parce que j'étais
en train de faire un travail sur lequel
politique de contrôle radicalisation en
france pour une pour une fondation
privée
je redemande rendez vous je tombe sur la
chargée de communication qui est une
française convertie
jeudi je voudrais vous rencontrer parce
que je voudrais parler de la
radicalisation votre point de vue etc
elle me dit de nous ça ne nous concerne
pas nous c'est la seule chose qui nous
concerne ce sont les actes islamophobes
en france je n'y tiens ça c'est
surprenant comme fatitude quand vous
avez un attentat comme les rats des
mouches et c'est donc vous devez avoir
une position publique
non non le dit elle ça ne nous concerne
pas et donc je le dis mais ça c'est
étonnant quand je parle à des goujats
place en parler avec le crif vous savez
c'est à dire que des kanaks de critiques
d'un juif c'est d'antisémitisme alors là
déjà elle était gênée elle a commencé à
sauter jeudi mais quand vous avez un
musulman radical et un juif intégré 6
tape dessus comment fait-on c'est de
l'islamophobie ou de l'antisémitisme
mais je sais pas pourquoi elle a
raccroché
donc on est sur des situations ciblés ou
de gens qui ne veulent pas participer au
débat républicain
ce sont des entrepreneurs politiques
sont des gens qui va l'être là que sur
un plateau télé dès qu'on dit le mot
islam
ils n'ont aucune représentativité ils
n'ont pas ils sont pas élus
c'est dire donc si vous voulez on a
affaire à des acteurs qui vont beaucoup
agir sur les réseaux sociaux très peu
sur le champ politique et c'est bien ça
qui est le danger donc j'essayais fait
partie effectivement de ces choses dont
la france pourrait aisément se
débarrasser parce que vraiment c'est pas
ça qui sert les musulmans et qu'est ce
qui justement s'avérait les musulmans
actuellement leur est fait en france
moi je crois que ce qui servirait
beaucoup les musulmans et je plaide pour
ça depuis très longtemps je le disais
déjà à l'époque en 2014 le véritable
évolution sociologique en france si
l'intégration de la communauté musulmane
on a tous autour de nous un banquier un
écrivain acteur de théâtre un homme aux
fonctionnaires etc qui sont des français
musulmans
ils ont trouvé leur place dans cette
société mais simplement on avait le tort
de chaque fois d interpeller quand irene
attentats d'hier vous vous êtes musulman
qu'est ce que vous en pensez elles ont
ils dit m attendais j'ai jamais sorti ma
carte de musulmans pourquoi
m'interpeller vous à ceux de cette façon
donc ces gens là si vous voulez ont
trouvé leur place dans la société mais
je me bats avec les chaînes d'info en
continu pour leur dire mais mettez les
sur le plateau des gens comme l'imam
chalghoumi qui est un imam républicain
qui s'est plusieurs fois opposé aux
radicaux dans les mosquées
tareq oubrou qui est un imam de bordeaux
etc des intellectuels comme farid
abdelkrim etc sont des gens qui se sont
déjà positionnés contre le radicalisme
mais simplement je dis moi mais moi je
peux pas parler en leur nom il faut les
amener pour montrer aux français que ces
musulmans sont républicains et voilà
donc c'est ça qu'on peut faire c'est les
mettre en avant c'est montrer qu'ils
sont importants et qui sont pratiquement
au front messieurs conesa parce que vous
estimez aujourd'hui qu'il y à beaucoup
de français
en tout cas peut-être une minorité qui
ne se rend pas vraiment compte que les
musulmans sont aussi des républicains
bah oui oui bien sûr parce que je me
retourne vers vous vous savez très bien
qu'il est toujours plus intéressant de
parler d'un train qui arrive en retard
que la traque qui arrivent à l'heure
donc faire un moment dire donner la
parole à des gens qui sont finalement
des gens normaux se retrouver leur place
dans cette république c'est
effectivement quelque chose qui peut pas
intéressé les médias par contre faire le
portrait d'un salafistes qui va vous
expliquer pourquoi la france est une
terre de m'écrire médiatiquement ça
marche beaucoup mieux
donc oui c'est évident vous savez la
france est le pays qui a la plus grosse
communauté juive la plus grosse
communauté arménienne la plus grosse
communauté musulmane est la plus grosse
commande
chinoise de l'ensemble des pays de
l'union européenne donc le modèle
d'intégration fonctionne ceux qui le
refusent sont une minorité de la
communauté musulmane
donc il serait temps de renverser leurs
discussions en disant rattrapé c'est pas
le modèle d'intégration qui fonctionne
pas ce sont des gens qui ne veulent pas
s'intégrer donc c'est pas la peine de
renverser et succinct battre la coulpe
si vous voulez non il ya un problème
effectivement de réception la france est
pleine de trous il ya là de droit
d'asile est un trou énorme le comment
dire l'application des lois par la
jurisprudence est un trou énorme et
c'est donc on a laissé pourrir une
situation dont on découvre tout à coup
qu'elle est devenue très très grave
et à ce moment là vous avez le choeur
des pleureuses qui vous explique qu'il
faut allumer des bougies amédée flore